[Music]
what the hell happened in the morning
and you can contextualize this however
sure no i mean what happened was
you know like i played a bunch of these
tournaments not not of ones quite this
size but i'd still played a lot of
tournaments at this point
and
i was there before before it actually
started usually people turn up late but
for some reason i was there in my chair
before the first hand was dealt and i
remember they the the company poker
stars whose event it was
you know they dimmed the lights like
welcome to ebt san remo huge we've got
incredible feel blah blah and then they
they dim the lights and they put on on
the screens around the room just like a
promo exciting video probably video you
know
and i remember distinctly the music it
was chemical brothers hey boy hey girl
which i always loved i always loved that
song yeah good choice yeah and you know
i was like oh this is cool i'm excited
and while i was just like listening to
it just
like out of nowhere this like
it's like a bolt of lightning felt like
it was like this like
and this voice in my head said you are
going to win this tournament
and it was handed out my own voice but
what i can't remember is whether it was
i am going to win or you are going to
win but i'm pretty sure it was you are
going to win but it literally sounded
like my own voice and it was sounded
like your own voice yes it was like that
you know when you speak in your head
like the voice you hear like at least i
think most people have that right like
you know that tuesday voice everyone
hears
oh man i'm letting you learning a lot
out here um
just you know uh it sounded like how i
would sound in my own head to myself
and it said you are going to win this
tournament
and
i got this rush of goosebumps like
really like that oh you know it's even
happening a little bit like the hair's
up on my arms to the point where i was
like what and i remember looking around
the room like did did i just say that
out loud did anyone else hear this and
everyone else was just like in their
phones or whatever and i was like
well that was freaky
then the lights came back up and they're
like okay cool shuffle up and deal and i
was still like stunned and i was like
okay cool and then i sort of a little
bit forgot about it but then like
halfway through the day i got in a big
pot and i lost half my chips
and you know it's always a bad feeling
when that happens and i was like oh man
i'm nearly out the tournament i guess
that was [ __ ] you know so like
though i had like little multiple
moments
over the next few days where
i
you know i i it clearly was a real thing
because i've like checked in on it you
know and i was like oh this and i even
told a friend of mine on the day
check checked in on it meaning you
remembered that it had happened that did
it happen well because obviously the
rational explanation to this is the like
it was just a false memory you know that
i have retroactively
remembered something that didn't really
happen as a way of like making
constructed
yes and i even have a friend my my
friend melanie who was there and i
bumped into her in the in the women's
bathroom on like day two and she's like
oh you've got a lot of chips it's going
well i was like yeah yeah things are
going well really weird i feel like i'm
going to win this in fact i like i
almost had a premonition that i did and
she's like yeah you seem really
confident and we actually had this
conversation and to the point that she
after i won it she was like what the
[ __ ] was that you you like predicted
this
i'm like i know i don't know
so
yeah
i don't know how to explain it
now
i think you said string or series
of experiences is that type of
experience in poker isolated to that
or i should and it doesn't have to be
constrained to poker right i'm just
wondering what other stories you may
have that
well
i so i had a few so what was interesting
was
i apologize for
doing this herky jerky questioning style
but did you have any of those types of
experiences when you were younger yeah
you recall no no
i was not like a weird kid or you know
that
had sorry let me start again
you weren't like the kid from the sixth
sense no i wasn't the sixth sense kid no
uh
no i did not is to answer that question
i had not really ever had i think
anything you know like i never saw a
ghost or anything like that i'm not
asking about ghosts i mean
don't love me in with the ghost hunters
come on i don't but that
i want to just paint the picture of that
i was a very in fact like a deep skeptic
right well you still are do you
skeptical right right but like certainly
then like i've never had anything weird
that i couldn't really explain in any
conventional way i've certainly not had
any time loops or anything like that or
weird voices in my head
but yeah to answer a question of like is
it a sort of common thing in poker no
not so much common thing in poker but
have you since had more of those types
of experiences
not of like explicit premonitions no i'm
not nothing even close to that i have
had
one really notable thing
that
is
yeah i i i am happy to talk about it if
you change your mind we can cut it later
exactly
for one for a better word i had an
extreme energy healing
an almost accidental one
so it was a few years ago and
seemingly out of the blue i started
getting this very unpleasant sensation
in my ear
where
particularly it was like a sort of
low frequency buzzing humming quite
frequently like so some kind of tinnitus
but it was almost like a pressure
and
voices particularly men's voices became
distorted to the point that they were
unbearable to listen to
and it was really bumming me out because
it would come in like clusters i would
have it like for a few hours and it
would go away and come later on in the
day
and
it was stopping me from doing any social
events because any any loud scenario was
unbearable but particularly men speaking
i just couldn't handle it
and this went on and off for a few
months and i went and saw a doctor
multiple doctors and had hearing tests
and they said oh you're losing your
hearing and the the low frequencies of
your of your hearing in that ear
we think you have meniere's disease
many years is this degenerative thing
which usually people end up completely
deaf when they have it where basically
the the nerve cells in the inner ears
start dying and they don't really know
why they think it's something to do with
like salts and ion channels and it's
incurable as far as i know and
and so i was told that's what i probably
have and they're like really sorry it's
you know it was just bad news to find
that out
and also because one of those
symptoms of it is you start having uh
balance problems as well you get like
these vertigo attacks and people like
vomiting and so on and so
you can imagine i was like really down
in the dumps finding this out
and then cut to
three months later or so uh go to
burning man and
i have for the first time one of these
vertigo attacks on one of the one of the
days i mean i wasn't completely sober
but um it was not a good time as you can
imagine having a vertigo attack while
not being sober for the first time so i
was then really down in the dumps and
then on the last night of the burn
i was talking to some you know some
friends and started talking to this girl
who i kind of i don't know that well
but she's a friend of a friend
and i mentioned about my ear and she's
like oh well i do energy healing i'm an
energy healer
i was like
i don't know what that is but sure do
whatever you want to do yeah have a go
she's like i can try
and
she sort of put her hand over my ear for
a few minutes and then she says i
remember saying something like there's
something there i need to get it and she
starts sucking over my ear with her
mouth like not touching it but just like
and it was really unpleasant because
like you can imagine that sensation of
someone like inhaling over your ear and
i was like oh please stop she's like no
i need to get this there's something
there
and she does it i don't know for a few
minutes and then eventually kind of
collapses in a heap on the floor crying
and freezing cold going oh my god that
was
that was bad i don't know what that was
that was really really bad
and
i again i was not fully sober so this is
a slightly uh you know retelling but i
just remember being so shocked
because i i just didn't expect anything
to actually happen i didn't really feel
anything other than this like unpleasant
sensation of her sucking but i was so
shocked at the way she was now reacting
because she was shocked she she did not
seem to expect whatever had just
happened to her and she said afterwards
you know she came around after a little
while and she's like i don't know what
it was it was like
bad energy i don't know it's gone i'm
very pleased to say it's fully gone and
it's it's gone away and i was like
well okay what does that mean for my
symptoms am i cured she's like yeah yeah
you'll probably have symptoms for a
couple more weeks and then you'll be
fine
and that's exactly what happened
and i haven't had any problems since
so yeah i don't know
uh it kind of just blew my world open
because
aside of that premonition thing which i
kind of forgotten about
i have not ever subscribed to
anything like that like i'm a physicist
in fact like you know i proud
i kind of built a career of being a like
materialist rationalist physicist
and i don't have any time for that stuff
it's all nonsense it's all confirmation
bias you know
like no one's ever actually tested it
empirically or proven it you know show
me the study and i'll believe it but
here i am
having that experience with like
two what feel like pretty
incontrovertible data points
that
something that i cannot explain
happened and fortunately would be
incredibly beneficial to me like such a
blessing
so yeah
you